[MUSIC PLAYING]
SERGEI VASILINETC:
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Sergei.
This is Adam and
Yigit with me today,
and we will speak about
LifeCycle problems.
So probably many of you attended
yesterday at Yigit's talk
where he introduced new
architecture components.
He introduced LiveData,
ViewModel, new persistence
slide named Room.
And today we will focus
on the LifeCycle part
of these architectural
components.
So we will speak again about
LiveData And ViewModel.
We will speak about LifeCycle
honors and LifeCycle that
are basics for these libraries.
But we will have more details.
We will have some reasoning
behind our decisions.
So if you attended yesterday,
it will be still interesting.
If you didn't
attend yesterday, we
will reintroduce
all of these things
so you will
understand everything.
So let's see what we have today.
Today we have an activity
in the fragments.
I'll start with is that not
for length length but dozens
and dozens line of lines.
And this line's the results
from a very natural process.
Google pay services
asked to register them
in onStart methods.
It's Your own components need
to know about this LifeCycle
event, so you need to forward
them in some kind of API.
And correspondingly,
on onStop method,
you have to call all
pairings stop methods,
and it's very easy
to forget one.
And will result in [INAUDIBLE].
It will drain the
user's battery,
and they will enjoy
your app a bit less.
Which is probably healthier for
them, but we think that's bad.
And they think the
answer in this situation
is to introduce LifeCycle
aware components.
So components which
handle LifeCycle.
And the first step
in this direction
is to introduce LifeCycle
as a first class citizen.
So it's a very
simple object which
answers the question, what is
the current state right now?
And notifies you
about new events.
And then no feature is important
but sounds ridiculous right
now, events and states
are different things.
So let's see what I mean.
Your case is instantiated
in initialized state.
And all creation phases
pass very routinely.
OnCreate, create the state.
OnStart, start the state,
same thing for resume.
But the road down is a
bit more interesting.
So onPause event, leads
you from a resume state
back to a starting state.
Not some new pause state,
or something like that.
And the reason for this is
from a system perspective,
the states after onPause event
and onStart event are the same
because the sets of the actions
that you are allowed to do
is the same.
And the same is true for
onStop and Creative state.
And last event is onDestroy.
It's pretty straightforward.
It brings it to destroy state.
Your activity is destroyed.
It's going to be thrown
away and garbage collected.
So let's make our
component LifeCycle aware.
That's super straightforward.
We take it with LifeCycle
observer interface,
accepted interface.
To get the actual events, we add
annotation and pass the events
that we are interested in,
you can pass multiple events
if you want to.
The last step is to add
ourselves as an observer.
And we may have a
potential problem here.
What if the activity is
already started at this point?
Does this mean that we are
going to receive onStop event,
and and we didn't
receive onStart.
And our component probably
is not ready for this.
But it took care
of it, and we bring
the observer to correct state.
So what does this mean?
Let's take this example,
which I just discussed.
From activity perspective
onStart and onCreate
create already happened, and
after that we add an observer.
But observer will still receive
onCreate and onStart events
immediately when
they were registered.
So let's take one step further.
OnResume, same situation.
Resume state will
bring to resume
state we got an onResume
event in addition to onCreate
and onStart.
A bit more
interesting situation,
onPause In this situation, we
are in a start state as well as
we learned.
So we bring the oberserver
to the correct state
which is start.
So it's a similar situation
as we had one minute ago.
Observer will receive
onCreate and onStart events,
and that's it.
So we don't have a
problem in this code.
So how to get this
magical lifecycle object?
We have this interface
which is super simple,
but this probably doesn't
help much right now.
And the actual
question is who are
LifeCycle owners out of box.
And the answer in this question
is support library fragments
and support activities.
But unfortunately, this is
true only in the bright future.
And right now we have
LifeCycle activity
and LifeCycle fragment.
But at the point
of 1.0 release, we
will merge our library to
support libraries so you
don't have to use them later.
And now Adam will speak
about some key differences
between fragment and
LifeCyle observers
ADAM POWELL: So if you've
been following along,
you probably recognize some
similarities with the fragment
API in this as well.
So at this point we've got
these two different components.
Which one do you use?
Well, as the slides are
already spoiling for you,
this really isn't an
either- or question.
One of these things doesn't
necessarily replace the other.
And here's why.
Fragments, on one hand, that
everybody knows and loves,
are statefully
managed and recreated
after either a process death,
an activity recreation,
or recreation of any hosts that
you have the fragment within.
Fragments manage views
and also interact
with the navigation
stack, which are
things that are firmly out
of scope of what LifeCycle
observers are meant to do.
Instead, LifeCycle
observers are meant
to enable more granular
factoring of your code,
whether you're in an
activity or a fragment.
They're stateless.
So that means that they
must be registered each time
the owner is recreated.
We're not going
to try to recreate
these magically for you.
They don't have any
concept of instant state
that they carry
around with them.
So these are meant to be
very, very lightweight,
so that you don't have a whole
lot of additional management
overhead.
And last, there's no relation
to the viewer navigation
management.
These really are meant
to be very tightly
scoped, isolated components.
So they can really
help everyone.
It means that it's much
simpler to integrate libraries
with your code, as long as
those libraries have provided
LifeCycle observer
aware components.
It means that you can break
up those really large fragment
or activity classes to make
them much simpler to understand
for a reader.
And you can provide much
more granular guarantees
around what operations are valid
at any given point in time.
You can make it so that if
an operation happens then
you're guaranteed to
be in a correct state
when something is called.
So LifeCycle owner
as already introduced
is just an interface.
Anyone can implement this.
This means that you
can improve testability
by creating your own.
You can create your own sort
of fragment-like library
implementations if
you feel so inclined.
But you can also create
composite life cycles.
Life cycles that span across
other smaller lifecycle
definitions.
So you can answer questions
like, is my app visible?
So this is a really
common composite lifecycle
that many of you may
be interested in.
It lets you do things
like session management
to track a particular
session across perhaps
some sort of a flow
or a series of logged
in versus logged out events.
And it may help you
with analytics as well.
So we have the process LifeCycle
owner as kind of a component
that I think a lot of you will
be interested in for this.
It's the composite lifecycle of
all the activities in your app.
So there's no configuration
changes to handle,
because we're not going to be
dealing with those from these.
The process LifeCycle
owner just stays
alive through the whole process.
But that also means that
you don't get state risk
restoration after process death
like we mentioned earlier.
So that means that
you don't have
to handle saving and
restoring that state
but at the same time, you need
to remember to re-register
these process lifecycle-based
observers if that's something
that you're working with.
So many indirect
components provide a lot
of deep plumbing
layers for things
that you can plug
into and work with.
But a lot of times
we've kind of omitted
the idea of higher
level components that
make use of that plumbing
so that you can just plug
play and go.
So do we have anything more
high level than the bare events
and states here?
YIGIT BOYAR: Maybe we do.
I will show you.
ADAM POWELL: Great
YIGIT BOYAR: Thanks, Adam.
So it's so nice
now you can observe
a LifeCycle is well-defined,
is a first class citizen.
But you still need to
deal with these things.
And we told like, there's
some common LifeCycle problems
that we should be able to
solve with this component.
So we'll look at the
problems that people
are having, and
this was probably
the most major problem
we've been seeing,
the untimely UI updates.
It's like your activity
receives a callback,
but the activity's
already stopped.
They tried to start a
new activity and crashes.
Or it tries to add a
fragment and crashes.
If an activity or a
fragment is stopped,
there is no reason to
update that activity.
You don't want to do that.
If the activity happens to
become visible again, then
you want to do it.
So we realized that this
is a very common problem,
and we wanted to solve this with
a higher level component which
we call LiveData.
When we look at the
LiveData in detail,
it's actually an
observable data holder.
It just holds on
to some information
that you can observe.
Now the difference
between LiveData
and your other observables
in data mining or RxJava
or whatever, is that
LiveData is LifeCycle aware.
It knows about
Android life cycles,
and when you want to
observe a LiveData,
you can pass in this
LifeCycle so that it
can manage your subscription.
The nice thing about LiveData
that is that you observe,
and that's all you do.
So if we look at
the usage example,
let's say we have an activity.
We receive a LiveData
from somewhere.
It doesn't really matter, and
now we call observe on it.
And when we are
calling observe, we
are passing this, which
is the LiveData owner.
That's all you need to say.
I want to observe this
LiveData within this LifeCycle.
Which also means if
this LifeCycle is gone,
I don't want to observe it.
Or if this LifeCycle is stopped,
I don't want to receive events.
And then once you do
this, that's all you do.
You don't need to
write onStart, onStop.
We want Android to want
to look more like this.
You initialze things as
more like find and forget.
You initialize, and you're done.
So let's look at what happens
when our activity starts
observing that LiveData.
So onCreate, it called observe,
it said LiveData is observable.
And as soon as the
activity starts,
it starts receiving
data changes.
So whenever the
LiveData value changes,
we displace that event
back to your observer
inside the activity.
It can also be a fragment.
Let's say a user
decides to rotate
the activity at this moment.
So you know that the
activity will be stopped.
And what happens
at the same time,
the LiveData happens
to be updated.
If that happens, we are not
going to tell the activity
about this change because there
cannot be any reason for you
to update the UI, because
it already stopped.
Similarly, if the
activity is destroyed,
we will automatically
remove that subscription
because that activity is gone.
There is no reason to
keep a reference back
to that activity.
Now we said the
activity was rotating,
so you know that
Android is going
to recreate that activity.
And then we are observing
the same LiveData back.
As soon as that
activity starts, it's
going to receive
last available data.
So your UI is going to have the
data before it gets a chance
to draw.
So similarly, I
say the user hits
the Home button, which means
the activity will be stopped.
Again, if the LiveData changes
while the activity is stopped,
it's not going to
receive any events.
Even if the data changes,
we are not going to tell it.
But as soon as if the user
comes back to the application,
we will give it the
last available data.
So this is why we call LiveData
is not just a stream of events.
It holds onto the data so
that if any observer comes,
it receives the last
available value.
And then eventually, the user
backs out of that activity,
and then we remove
that subscription.
You can also extend
the LiveData class.
Because LiveData provides
two really handy callbacks.
The first one is called
onactive which means
you have an active observer.
Another one is
called oninactive,
which means you don't
have any observers,
so don't bother
changing your value
if it is something
that you care about.
You probably ask now what
is an active observer?
An active observer
is an observer
whose attached LifeCycle
is started or resumed.
So it's like a fragment that's
currently visible to the user.
If the fragment is
on the back stack,
the user is not seeing it.
It stopped, so it's not active.
There's no reason to do
any work for that fragment.
Let's see how we can take
advantage of these named
callbacks.
We are going to create
a new location LiveData
class, which presents
the location of something
on the device.
So we say this data holds
an instance of a location.
In cross-sector, we just
get the location manager
from the system service.
There's nothing fancy here.
We have a listener whenever
the system server sends us
any location, we just
call setValue on us.
This all you do.
There is no LifeCycle
handling here.
You just call setValue,
and LiveData takes
care of handling the LifeCycle.
And you may have any
number of observers.
It doesn't really matter.
So we want to override onactive.
The very first active
observer comes.
We want to start listening
to the system service.
Similarly, when the last
active observer goes away,
we want to stop observing
the system service.
Now if you look at that
location LiveData class
we just created in the
previous example, let's look
at the properties of that class.
First of all, it
is LifeCycle area.
It knows when to start
itself, when to stop itself.
You just don't need
to babysit it anymore.
It is self-sufficient.
You start it.
You forget about it.
It can be a singleton.
Like all of the subscriptions
are automatically
managed for you.
So if the data is logically
singleton your codebase,
you can make the LiveData
instance singleton.
So there's this
thing where normally
if you keep referencing
an activity or a fragment
from a certain context,
that will be a big no no.
But if you are using
LiveData it is yes yes,
because we manage the
substitution for you.
So you also don't need to
subclass LiveData all the time.
So if you just need
an instance of it
but you already
have the value, you
could use this mutable
LiveData class,
which comes inside the library
that has a public setter.
But usually when you
are using this class,
internally you will have
it but the API you expose
will just return a
LiveData, because you
don't want to expose
the fact that anyone
can set the value on it.
Now when we were designing
these LifeCycle components,
the LiveData, see we
spent a lot of time
to get rid of one exception.
This fragment exception that I--
[APPLAUSE]
We really wanted to say, please,
no more fragment transaction
exceptions.
So LiveData guarantees that
if you received anywhere,
you could run a
fragment transaction.
And to see how we are making
it part of the history,
I want to invite Adam
back to explain it to us.
ADAM POWELL: All
right, so anyone
who has received one
of these exceptions
realizes that it
doesn't just come
from trying to do something
when you just completely stopped
and you absolutely know it.
These exceptions
tend to come in when
you get into very intricate,
nested life cycles.
So we wanted to make sure to be
very thoughtful about defining
how the LifeCycle observer
callbacks are invoked and when.
So in a case like
this, what happens?
You have defined handler
for the stop event.
So in the container
your activity onStop,
you want to make sure that you
don't get an onChanged event
after the onStop has happened.
But in order for
that to happen, what
needs to be true
about when we actually
invoke all of the
onStop listeners
that are attached
to these observers.
So we have to define a
really strict order for this.
So as we go through create
and start and onResume,
we know that we need
to invoke the LifeCycle
observers after the
container event happens.
So you know in your
observer that everything
about your LifeCycle
owner has been configured.
If you check any
state about it, you
know that you're already
completely in that state.
But that means something
really special for coming
back down the other direction.
It means that when the activity
starts to become paused,
you want your
LifeCycle observers
to be able to shut down
anything that they're
doing before the activity
does all of the work
to actually become paused.
Similar for stop.
And this is where
this becomes really
important for the fragment
transaction exception.
You want to make
sure that you're
recording, that you're fully
stopped before the fragment
system goes through
and flags everything
as being completely locked out.
So what that means is that the
stop event of your LifeCycle
observer will always be invoked
before the activity onStop
or before the full stop event
for your container happens.
So this seems really similar
to some other libraries
that some people may
have seen in the past.
Can you talk about that?
SERGEI VASILINETC: Yes, when we
create new observable pattern,
nowadays this question
is unavoidable.
Is it another RxJava?
And the answer to
this question is, yes,
because we want to promote
a reactive programming
model, especially when it
comes to the relationship
between your UI and the
state [INAUDIBLE] UI.
We want you to react on
the changes of the state.
So it means that it's a
reactive programming model.
But on the other hand, no.
Because it's the LifeCycle
aware out of box,
as Yigit mentioned,
and it's much easier.
As many of you may know,
the learning curve of RxJava
is super steep.
And if you have an
Android learner curve,
and after that we add RxJava
learning curve on top of it,
it becomes very
hard to new people
to start to develop
on our platform.
So we can't just say to them,
oh let's go, just learn this,
that's it. .
No, but if you already
learned RxJava,
we don't expect you to migrate
from it to our solution.
Because you already
passed the learning curve,
you and your coworkers are
comfortable with it, fine.
We are totally fine with this.
But one thing we ask
you to do is to be sure
that you manage LifeCycle.
RxJava has common
approaches to solve this.
Be sure to use it and
everything will be fine.
But when you start a new app,
I think this model is the best.
The best is to start the project
with LiveData, because it's
simpler, it's faster,
it's lightweight,
it's well integrated
with a framework.
And if you feel like you love
reacting programming a lot,
you want to bring it
not only to relation
between UI and the state.
You want to bring
it to the business
part of your application.
Then you may consider
the addition of RxJava,
because it gives you more power.
And we will actually
help you to do that.
We have this extension
to our library, which
gives a possibility to create
LiveData from Publisher
and create Publisher
from LiveData.
So this integration
should be quite smooth.
But I want to highlight a
key difference between RxJava
and LiveData.
So as Yigit already
said, LiveData
is a holder and not a stream.
So we have a reference
to the last value,
and observers immediately
receive the last value when
they start to observe LiveData.
And now the big difference
is a threading model.
As you know, RxJava has a very
sophisticated threading model.
It's extremely powerful,
but in most cases,
you probably don't need it.
And we have everything
on the main thread.
And the reason for
this is we want
to give you all these guarantees
about when we will notify you
about state changes.
And we can't do this
on a background thread.
We have just the one exception.
We have a post
value method which
just is a method
which trampoline value
from a background thread to the
main thread and sets it there.
It's super simple.
So quick summary of what
we have at this point.
LiveData events,
observable pattern
which respects these events.
But there is one big thing
which is not covered yet.
And this is how to handle
onConfigurationChanges.
In 2017, almost nine
years after Android
was first time released, we
still discuss this question.
And this is a totally
legit question.
And we hear it constantly
from new Android developers.
Many of you probably know
whats the deal with it.
But let's take a look at
this oversimplified example,
but it's still very vivid.
So he wants to show
this information
about user and your activity.
And you want to make
some web service request.
We will use LiveData to get
this result. It's super simple.
When the request is just
started, it's empty.
When the request
response is received,
we put it to
LiveData as a value.
And later we'll update our UI.
We will notify the activity, and
it will do everything it needs.
So what happens if the activity
is going to [INAUDIBLE].
We're going to
make a call twice,
and I hope that you don't
call web service right
into your activity.
But you probably have
some abstractions
that does something
like that, which
goes to a network, which goes
to caching and persistence
storages.
And all the separations
are synchronized by nature.
So communication of these
components are synchronized.
And you probably don't want to
make these calls twice anyway.
So what you want
to do is to cache.
This is our data,
like in our example.
And what are the ways
today to do that?
Well, one of a
proposed way to do it
is a Fragment.setRetainInstance,
and Yigit
can rant about this for hours.
Unfortunately, we don't
have time for this today.
But I just say that
the only effect
that you have to run
fragment transaction
is terrifying for
a lot of people.
People go nuts and
another possible way
to solve this is loaders, but
we don't fit here well as well.
So we decided to tackle
this problem once again
and create ViewModel.
So what is this?
ViewModel is an object
which is associated
with a fragment or an
activity, but is retained
during configuration changes.
So its scope is a kind of a
logical scope of your activity.
So what does this mean?
Let's see.
If we have access time and
the current moment, and we
can predict the future.
And we know that activity
is going to be created,
and this means that
all construction
events are going to happen.
During onCreate we will request
ViewModel for the first time.
We will create it, and
after that this activity
just uses this ViewModel.
Very simple.
Now we predict that the
activity is going to be rotated.
Let's see what's going to
happen with our ViewModel.
We will receive events,
onPause, onStop, and onDestroy.
But when all the
segments are cured
and your activity is
destroyed, it's thrown away
and is garbage collected,
ViewModel survived it.
And the new activity, which was
created in place the old one
uses the same, old object.
So you can easily cache
there LiveData as we want to
or something else.
The last case, what
is going to happen
if you have finished goal?
Once again, we will receive
these destruction events,
but this time,
ViewModel is available
until onDestroy method.
During onDestroy method, we
will call onClear on this.
Which notifies you if you have
any currently running actions
or any resources
its time to close.
And after that, it's
going to be destroyed
and garbage collected as well.
So at the point when your
activity is destroyed,
it's not going to be
recreated it again.
Your ViewModel is gone as well.
So let's quickly make
our sample in ViewModel.
So it starts with
instantiating-- with creation
of ViewModel class.
We want to cache for user data
to create a fill for that.
We agree our activity needs
to access this LiveData,
so we create a getter for this.
And finally, getter is
extremely straightforward.
If we already requested the
data, we just return it.
If the data is now, we'll
request it from a web service
and return it.
Fine.
We had [INAUDIBLE]
on our activity.
Now we need to get this
LiveData from ViewModel.
To get it, we need to create
to get ViewModel somehow.
So this is how we do it.
Let's take a precise look at it.
First of all, we need to get
ViewModel provider object.
This is an object
which is associated
with a fragment or an activity.
It knows how to get already
existing ViewModel from it
or how to create a new one.
If there is no
existing ViewModel.
After that, we request
our myActivity ViewModel,
and later everything
is quite simple.
We get the userData.
We observe it to update the UI.
So what are the rules
of usage of ViewModel?
So ViewModel manages
the data for the UI.
It means that it
speaks with business
parts of your application
to retrieve the data.
So it may be a repository
pattern or any other pattern
that they use.
It also, it's for its
user modifications
back to these components.
And now a good
case for ViewModel
is acting as a communication
layer between fragments
in one activity.
And Yigit will speak
about this later.
But prior to this,
things that you must not
do in your ViewModel.
So first of all,
you must not access
views and any other
UI- related entities.
The reason for
that, they are going
to be created during
configuration change.
If you try to use them, you will
ever use stale data from there,
ever to leak them.
That's going to finish bad.
And it's fragmented
or activity's job
to bind the data which you
will get from a ViewModel
with actual UI,
text use, buttons.
I don't know what else.
And one more thing,
there are sources
which sound more harmless
like strings or drawable,
and you may think,
I may cash it here.
No, they depend on current
configuration state of state
as well.
So yes, right now you may
have just one resource
for every configuration,
but later, you
will add in the same resource
for a different configuration.
You will easily forget
to update your ViewModel.
And you may not notice
this, but your users
will see the invalid UI.
And this is just ugly.
And now Yigit will speak about
Inter Fragment communications.
YIGIT BOYAR: So I
want to talk about one
of my favorite features
about ViewModel,
which is communicating
between multiple fragments
of the same activity.
It's good that UI like this,
like the Gmail on the tablet
where on the left side you pick
an email and on the right side,
it shows the contents
of the email.
Now usually you will
implement this as a fragment
on the left which picks
something from the list,
and another fragment
on the right, which
shows how to show the
contents of an email
so that if you're on the
phone you can reuse the same
fragments but separate
from each other.
Now if you ever tried to write
a UI like this, if you ever
tried to make these two
fragments talk to each other,
it's a pain in the neck.
It's very, very hard.
Like you need to
create an interface.
But then what if
one fragment gets
created before the other one.
An activity needs to
talk to each other.
Or like when the
activities are restored,
you don't really
know which fragment
will be restored first.
It is really hard to
manage this state.
But we can actually solve this
very elegantly using ViewModel.
So let's say so these two
families actually want
to talk about a selected email.
This is the information
they want to share.
So let's put it
inside a ViewModel
and we are going to call
this shared ViewModel.
So it has a mutable
LiveData inside it
which you call selected, and it
provides two very simple APIs.
The first one says, set the
select email to this email.
Another one says, get the
selected email as a LiveData.
It's a really simple ViewModel.
But now once we have this,
let's go back to our fragments
and see how we can use this.
So inside the content
fragment, which is the one
that wants to display the
contents of the email.
It wants to know when the
selected email changes.
So we're going to go-- so
we have already seen this.
You can go to ViewModel
providers class
and get the ViewModel
providers of this fragment.
But we actually want ViewModel
not from this fragment,
we want it from our activity.
So all you have to do tell it
to do it from your activity.
Now it's going to return your
ViewModel in the activity
scope, and I will say, get
for the shared ViewModel.
Now, the very first time one
of the fragments called this,
we are going to
create a new one.
When the other
fragment comes alive,
it's going to receive the
same ViewModel instance.
And I will do the same thing.
So this one says, get
the selected email.
Start observing on it.
Really similarly, in
the select fragment
which was the one on the
left by user pics and email,
we get the same ViewModel.
And whenever the user selects
an email from the list,
we just call the
ViewModel- related method
to change the selected email.
Now these two fragments
talking to each other
without actually
talking to each other.
How does this really happen?
So if we go back to our UI.
So we have the selector on the
left, the content on the right.
But if you look at the
details, actually both of these
are talking to a
shared ViewModel.
They never talk to each other.
The video of this solution is
that if you're on the phone,
let's say one fragment
replaces the other one,
there's no room for error.
Like the fragment still
talks to a ViewModel.
ViewModels always that
nothing will crash.
They don't even care
the other one is there.
Okay, so this is a
lot of information,
and there's further
details about how
these life cycles work.
We really spent a
lot of time to make
these handle most common
used cases on Android.
So we come in just
the first trade out.
You could try it
now, in [INAUDIBLE].
Please check out all of the
architecture components.
These are things that actually
work very well together.
We have an architecture
guide which shows you
how to use these things together
to write a good application.
And also check our code labs.
We have code lab sections that
will give you a first glimpse
of how LifeCycles work.
Thank you
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]